so if you look at Dark Star it's sort of
like a comedic student film version of
alien cuz Dan O'Bannon who wrote alien
wrote darks oh don't get me started I
know Batman is the best you actually
have a Dan O'Bannon Asst about you thank
you you really sort of look very Dan
O'Bannon edge II like right I can see
we're out of time
thanks I could do this all day long I'm
actually cooking something pretty cool
right now it's a new movie where a film
journalist is taken hostage so it's like
you'd like literally you're the first
person I'm telling it to that sounds
like an amazing idea yep tell your
friends yeah no seriously let your
friends know you have any friends that
you know want to be movie stars again so
he tells me it's about a movie reporter
who's taken hostage right and so he
still looks at me and he says hey tell
all your friends because I'm casting
this today what did you say and that's a
big deal yeah yeah that's what I'm
saying guys it's true it's probably
gonna be like a whole franchise well of
course it is captain donut
listen if he thinks I'm not getting
points on this thing he's a fool and
Brittany you know how much I value the
back end don't touch me we're
just be serious here for a minute all
right if I'm not mistaken I'm the only
person here who's done a two-episode arc
on Franklin and bash you guys remember
it I was very good Breckin Meyer good
friend of mine said I was so blind guys
the fact of the matter is one of our
lives is gonna change today right
Christopher
okay baby let's take a selfie oh my god
are you okay
I get it I have like great teeth I never
had braces my skin's perfect my eyes are
beautiful
I'm definitely touched by the hand of
Jesus but like it's just I really had
the secret dream of being an actor you
know and my parents they've never
supported it oh honey your parents sound
like assholes I'm just feeling really
ugly I don't know it's just
Christopher you're one of the most
beautiful men I've ever laid eyes on and
I'm including myself in a man's wig I'm
gonna get real with you for a second
if you want to be an actor be an actor
if you want to be a garbage man be a
garbage man you know what I'm saying
though you need to get out there and you
need to take what's yours because you
only live once as far as we know all
right I love you but just not okay sorry
just like I'm gonna do it go go Yolo
that's good I should hash tag Yolo well
has anyone ever done that
hey buzz buzz buzz Christopher David yes
I'm absolutely inaccurately I wanted to
make something that's more in the
tarkovsky so Larry it's not there for a
second do you get a chance to watch any
of the stuff they're doing over at TNT
it's Franklin and bash you seen any of
that's really good no I've been a little
busy lately
dylan mcdermott derma rolling dylan
mcdermott Dermot Mulroney my name is
Benedict Cumberbatch I really wanted to
do something that was somewhere between
a mix of Blair which he just give you
this I was also playing myself
Ian step up 3d information on the back
and good luck with this project it looks
terrific cute your job James Franco
you're Dave Frank I have exact f90 de
Frank oh it's interesting because I
hear you're kind of looking for the next
big star for your next film obviously
Dekker to talk to some other people
are you sure dude James Franco buddy
look at your like a beer I love
horror I love science fiction I was
voted most likely to get murdered in
high school you were I don't know if
you're planning any other horror movies
you sort of need a good horror movie
scream I have that coming here yes yeah
I'm looking for Christopher hey what are
you doing in there
Hey yesterday hi hi oh god does anyone
have a towel the butt
Piero's my pure elephant I suppose
buzzes it's for David mm-hmm both do you
do you have a question tell me why don't
I just start let me tell you about
mission fear
I'm so excited questions yeah for you
okay you know do you you know a lot of
people don't know this about me but I've
always wanted to do sci-fi it's like in
this secret dream secret dream is that
what you just said it's a secret dream
oh my god it's your secret dream please
out hey what's going on you guys
Christopher went nuts in there he's
holding a hostage not to make this about
me but I feel like this might be my
fault I accidentally told Christopher he
was important why would you do that hey
you guys seen my phone charger shut up
okay
haha wow what a challenge is big news I
booked it okay we're just gonna take it
down I know Jay Hernandez I mean the
rules still up for grabs